j'ai tout essayé j'ai tout fait et on
n'a pas été aidé on a été lâché
complètement aucun soutien ni avant ni
pendant et ni après l'adolescente était
harcelée depuis septembre par d'autres
collégiennes en février déjà elle avait
été une lettre d'adieu lui ce matin par
l'avocat de la famille chers parents si
vous lisez cette lettre c'est que je
suis sûrement parti je suis désolé
d'avoir fait ça mais je n'en pouvais
plus alors l'école à l'évidence il
s'agit d'un échec collectif l'avocat
annonce le dépôt de quatre plaintes pour
non-assistance à personne en péril
contre le directeur du collège
l'académie de Lille les policiers
Facebook et Instagram à l'issue de cette
enquête administrative qui sera menée
par des inspecteurs généraux j'en
tirerais toutes les conclusions les
conclusions à l'égard des personnels le
cas échéant mais je ne veux pas la loi
visant à encadrer les influenceurs a été
adopté à l'unanimité hier soir par 94
votants à l'Assemblée nationale je pense
qu'il devrait y avoir dans les écoles
une pédagogie sur la question de
l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux ce
n'est pas fait le texte prévoit entre
autres d'interdire certaines pratiques
comme la promotion de la chirurgie
esthétique la mise en avant de produits
contenants de la nicotine ou encore
empêcher la publicité pour les
pronostics sportifs en cas de manquement
les peines peuvent aller jusqu'à 2 ans
de prison et 300000 euros d'amende ces
immeubles du centre ville de nantoua
dans l'Ain que le tireur s'était
retranché ce matin l'homme d'une
trentaine d'années armée ouvre le feu
dans un bar il touche mortellement un
homme de 19 ans épaisse deux autres
personnes regardez ce qu'elle dit
Isabelle borne il m'a assuré Emmanuel
Macron de sa confiance et a déclaré que
s'il avait eu quelque chose à me dire il
l'aurait fait en tête-à-tête certains
manifestement ont du mal à comprendre ça
fait des années maintenant que Emmanuel
Macron dit il faut
combattre le rassemblement national sur
le des fonds sur le terrain des idées
mais on n'a jamais vu ça arrivait je le
regrette j'aimerais bien qu'on combatte
sur le plan des idées je rêve que de ça
ce qui s'est passé c'est des scènes
assez ahurissantes forme d'intimidation
je parle même pas des hurlements des
cris des tentatives d'obstruction qui
était manifestent de la part de la
France insoumise on vit un peu vous
prendre prendre une image d'un enfant
qui lorsqu'il a perdu un jeu de société
renverse la table et quitte la pièce en
hurlant c'est un peu ça qui s'est passé
hier ils ont perdu c'est
systématiquement ça avec les mélanges
phonistes quand la démocratie parle mais
ne va pas dans leur sens ça voudrait
dire qu'il n'y a pas de démocratie vous
parleriez de dérive mafieuse je crois
que c'est Mathieu
je vous dis quelque chose d'aussi grave
dans quelle probabilité que l'article 1
soit à l'ordre du jour de la séance
plénière du 8 juin
faible l'hôtel de l'église protestante
Saint-Guillaume est la scène d'un opéra
de Pergolèse la Servante maîtresse une
version adaptée pour y inclure les
performances d'anacrobates champion de
Paul dance un blasphème pour certains
qui n'ont pas hésité à écrire et menacer
de mort le pasteur de la paroisse 150
pilotes du monde entier se sont donnés
rendez-vous dans les Alpes je viens de
Roumanie je suis de Colombie
sur l'aire de décollage les départs
s'enchaînent
je trouve que c'est donner vraiment un
mauvais signal de plein t'ont été
déposés la sécurité renforcée et les 530
places ont trouvé preneur c'est une
personne qui ne sait pas tenir sa parole
c'est une personne elle est pas la même
quand tu la vois mais après les
élections vous en rendez compte quand
même non parce que le visage que j'avais
avant les élections et la face que j'ai
eu après les élections c'était deux
choses différentes les parapente se
frôle sont jamais se toucher grâce à la
maîtrise des pilotes leurs ailes
colorent le ciel sous le regard
impressionné du public
parce qu'on m’était pas comme un vanupié
mais je sais qu'elle me mettait des
bateaux dans les roues partout et puis
admet pas vraiment dans son cœur sympa
on a fait allez 20 minutes sur la
situation sociale et on bascule sur les
élections 2022
l'urticaire c'est bien pour ça qu'on
n'est pas crédible vis-à-vis des
Français